فقد قال عمده كيف انفجارات دوت في منطقه
سيدي نبرافسكي ومن جهتها كشفت الاداره
الاقليميه للعاصمه ان هجوم صاروخيا على
كيف استهدف منشئه للمنيه التحتيه كما اعلن
التاهب الجوي في مقاطعه الاوكرانيات عده
هذه الاثناء قالت هيئه الاركان ان قواتها
الجويه استهدفت مواقع القوات الروسيه داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات الماضيه
كما قصفت المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
طل بعضها البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في منطقه
كونستان
صاروخيه على طول خطوط الجبهات لاسيه
جاتا قناه القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
خرسون ان القوات الروسيه تعزز من
تحصيناتها الدفاعيه على طول ضفه الشرقيه
التي تسيطر عليها عند نهر دنبر قال
المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في
المدينه
ان القوات الرئيسيه ترد على القصف
الاوكراني المتواصل لمواقعها بقصف المناطق
المدنيه المستعاده محاوله الضغط على ما
تبقى من سكان
هو احد وسائل الضغط النفسيه
بل ايضا على سكان الضفه الشرقيه المحتله
من نهر دنابر يريدون القول انما تتعرض له
خير صور حاليا من قصر المناطق السكنيه
واستهداف البنيه التحتيه سيتكرر في مناطق
الضفه الشرقيه للنهار اذا ما وصلت اليها
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في العموم
الوضع لا يزال صعبنا على طول ضفتينا
الدينار
خطوطهم الدفاعيه في الضفه المحتله ويخلفون
وراءهم حقول الغام وينفجون عمليات تجميع
وانتشار دوريه لقوتهم